in dieser Sendung wird immer Deutschland
kritisiert wird wie drehen da die
Politiker durch den Fleischwolf wir
wissen alles besser wir wissen der liebe
Gott weiß alles wir wissen alles besser
und damit immer fürchterlich kritisiert
und Deutschland kommt oftmals etwas
schlecht weg vor allem das politische
deshalb habe ich hier ein Thema nachdem
sich alle deutschen besser fühlen können
denn es gibt eben auch in anderen
Ländern fürchterlich durchgeknallte
Menschen zum Beispiel in der Schweiz und
dort sind sie im Raum der
Normalverteilung auch in der Politik
einzutreffen und diese durchgeknallten
haben in der Schweiz jetzt ein neues
Gesetz verabschiedet das in unserer
Demokratie auch angenommen werden wird
ein neues Ehegesetz und in diesem
Ehegesetz wird der Vater gestrichen also
die Schweiz schafft den Vater ab wir
haben ein Partnerschaft seit Ehegesetz
in dem das Wort Vater nicht mehr
vorkommt wohl aber Mutter das Wort Vater
wird aber setzt durch Elternteil und
jetzt kommt es durch Samenspender und
das ist nämlich das nehme ich persönlich
das ist ein unglaublicher affron ich bin
vierfacher Vater ich werde jetzt von
diesen feministischen Wahnsinn als Mann
zurückgestuft vom Vater zum Samenspender
zu einer Art Nutztier zu einem
zertifizierten Zuchttier den
Samenspenden dürfen nur die dies
Vorarbeiten Behörden angemeldet haben
ich finde das ist fürchterlich aber
bevor er zu fest lacht hier ich sage
euch das kommt nach Deutschland denn ihr
habt hier schon Politiker in Reutlingen
da kandidiert ein Mann für die Grünen
als Frau und dann haben sie gefragt
wieso kandidieren Sie als Frau für ein
politisches Amt und sagt ja weil es im
Einklang mit unserem Parteiprogramm ist
das Geschlecht ist eine persönliche
Entscheidung also der Wahnsinn pflanzt
sich schneller fort als das Coronavirus
ihr seid nicht sicher deutsche Männer
während den Anfängen
also den Vater auszuradieren ist
wirklich da bin ich froh dass die
Schweizer zuerst gemacht haben denn ich
glaube du hast recht das setzt ja quasi
eine eine Kette von irsche nicht rein
also
Annalena baerburg wenn ich das richtig
erinnere auch Gesetzestexte Gendern also
das heißt
geschlechtsneutral formulieren
das ist eine wir sind da glaube ich auf
einem Weg der Selbstvergessenheit in
einen in einen
absurden Zustand des keiner weiß mehr
wer wirklich ist denn vielleicht hält
sich dann irgendwann den Vater auch
selber nicht mehr von Vater
vermutlich einmal glücklich gewesen über
das Gesetz Boris Becker wäre vermutlich
zumindest einmal nach Hause gehen
aber es zeigt doch auch wir beschäftigen
uns inzwischen in unseren politischen
extrem elitären bubbles mit Themen die
nur noch auf eine Sache Hinweisen wir
kennen keine Probleme mehr nur
Gesellschaften die wirklich über
Jahrzehnte frei von Armut wenn ich höre
wie arm Deutschland angeblich ist gerade
in dem Wahlkampf das ist über meine
Damen und herrscht wenn wir uns mit
diesen Themen die ganze Zeit
beschäftigen welcher Gesetzestext wie
geändert werden soll
ob man noch Schwarzfahrer sagen darf ja
oder nein das kann ja nur darauf
hindeuten und das ist ja eigentlich eine
gute Nachricht dass wir seit Jahrzehnten
überhaupt gar keine ernsthaften Probleme
mehr kennen aber das Verrückte ist wir
haben sie ja jetzt was ist das also wir
haben ja Pandemie wir haben ja große
Unwetter und ihre Milliarden folgen wir
haben ja eine instabile internationale
Situation wir haben ja eine Ausbreitung
des Islamismus wir haben ja ein
Integrationsproblem von Menschen die zu
uns gekommen sind also wir haben ja jede
Menge Probleme vielleicht ist es so eine
Ersatzhandlung um sich mit den
wirklichen Problemen
und das wäre aber ganz gefährlich weil
das ist nämlich wie ein Autofahrer der
zwar seine Bremse nicht die nicht
funktioniert
das ist die Realitätsflucht in den
Wahnsinn den man für die Wirklichkeit
hält und das ist genau die Verbindung
von irgendwelchen scheinproblemen man
steigert sich in etwas hinein um genau
wie du sagst nicht über die eigentlichen
Wirklichkeiten zu stellen
Realitätsflucht eine würde ich so sagen
eine pervertierte Form der Romantik ich
bin nicht gegen Romantik aber Romantik
die dann in den Wahnsinn sich davon
träumt dann sind wir bei der Abschaffung
des Vaters das sind wir bei der
Abschaffung der Wirklichkeit und da sage
ich jede wetten das Sendung mit Thomas
Gottschalk hatte mehr Faktizität mehr
Wirklichkeitsgehalt mehr Realitätsgehalt
als die Politik die heute gemacht wird
stimmt da sollten wir Schluss verstehen
lassen
noch ein paar Minuten also 3 Minuten
aber stimmt doch ja ich bin der auch der
Mann natürlich habe ich oft auch
darunter gelitten dass ich um 20 Uhr die
Tagesschau gesehen hatte oder die
Tagesthemen oder was auch immer und dann
einmarschiert bin und gesagt haben und
hier kommt einer der eine Kuckucksuhr
blind mit in drei Minuten zusammenbaut
habe die Welt keinen anderen Probleme ja
sie hatte sie aber wenn der Showmaster
schon darunter leidet dass ihr die Show
in den Vordergrund seines seines Wesens
und seines Seins stellt und nicht die
Wirklichkeit jetzt bin Gott sei Dank die
Politik folgt mir auf dem Fussel heute
ist im Entertainment ist mehr Realität
als in der Politik aber das ist
natürlich auch das Versagen diese
Journalisten hier am Tisch die bringen
es offensichtlich nicht fertig diese
Politiker so zu steuern dass sie sich
mit der Wirklichkeit auseinandersetzen
die müssen mehr Fernsehen schauen
zu entdecken für mich übrigens das
schönste dieser nischenthemen gerade
hochgekommen letzte Anekdote ein junger
Mann der gesagt hat ich habe eine
Sexualität entdeckt meine sexuelle
Orientierung ich nenne mich super
straight super straight heißt ich stehe
auf Frauen die immer Frauen waren als
Frauen geboren wurden und sich selber
als Frauen empfinden sprich einfach ganz
normal ich stehe auf Frauen der ist für
dieses Video auf diversen Social Media
Plattform gesperrt wurden ja weil es als
feindselig gegenüber Menschen gegolten
hat die sich dort nicht so wirklich
zuordnen können meine Liebste Anekdote
aus dem Walk Wahnsinn der letzten der
vergangenen der vergangenen Wochen und
da gehört das ja auch so ein bisschen da
ist jetzt also die Schweiz schlechter
dran da können sich die Deutschen noch
zurücklehnen leicht amüsiert und sagen
es gibt doch noch Länder in denen es
verrückter läuft als bei uns zumindest
in diesem Bereich das haben wir uns oft
immer gesagt wir haben immer gerne auf
die Schweiz geguckt und gesagt mein
Schweizern ist es noch ein bisschen
verrückter aber
[Musik]